hi I'm Courtney act you can watch
Courtney acts Christmas Extravaganza but
today I'm here for BuzzFeed first time
first job I think my first like actual
real job was as a door-to-door sales
person for Foxtel like a cable cable
cable cable TV cable TV company and that
lasted a couple of weeks because I got
look I won't say held at sword point but
I was kept in someone's house against my
will and she did have a sword and was
sort of brandishing it it was kind of in
a fun jokey way but as an 18 year olds I
did find that quite confronting and as
soon as she turned around I made her
dash for the door and I no longer worth
selling cable door-to-door first time on
the drag-race set what was walking into
the workroom when I said is this
America's Next Top Model and I think the
thing that you're really taking pass
that you realize it's actually a set I
genuinely had always thought that robust
this sounds dumb I just always thought
that it was like shot in the basement of
rupaul's house because he's sort of like
walks down and always pictured him up in
upstairs in his sunken living room and
sort of like alright time to go down and
see the girls and he'd sort of traipse
down the steps into the basement the
well-lit basement for the basement
nonetheless and then I was like wait a
minute these aren't real bricks they're
just photographs of bricks printed onto
fabric it's all an illusion first drag
show you ever attended oh that would
have been at the Aubrey Hotel in the
year 2000 I remember being quite
confused because they were you know a
very draggy looking in a Priscilla kind
of way like big make of a big hair quite
garish and and quite masculine they all
had what we called corsets which was
sort of really high cut tight corsets
and I just remember being quite
fascinated by the idea that all of these
men had their penises removed to do drag
and then I later learned about the
ancient art of tucking which is sort of
like somewhere between gift wrapping and
stuff
Turkey first song you ever perform well
in drag was dance ten looks three from A
Chorus Line tips and ass spa pass off a
fancy pair tightened up the dairy yeah
did the nose with it all the girls with
that that was a good one I wore um it
was a scarf but I worried as a dress and
it was kind of like furry and it had
holes and it was like a dress cough I
feel like it was like not the infinity
dress but like maybe it had a few
options and it was like a tube and had
sleeves in it and my one wig which what
was she called Gillian I think she was
called Gillian first time you met a
celebrity maybe Paris Hilton in 2003 at
the matrix the film The Matrix launched
at the Sydney Opera House we ended up
hanging out all night and dancing till
the Sun came up and and sort of hung out
a bunch while she was in Australia
there's other stories about Paris that I
talked about on Big Brother's which I
I'm not gonna say it was a
cease-and-desist it's I shan't be
talking about any further thank you
first time you went on a date yeah do
you want all of the juice oh sorry juice
that really makes it I remember during
the Titanic movie making out with my
then girlfriend and also so there's that
movie fear with Mark Wahlberg and he and
his girlfriend are on the roller coaster
and they're going up the roller coaster
and he's doing something to her and then
when they get to the top she's like yeah
that was in Titanic with my girlfriend
also we both had braces and she kind of
kissed like a helicopter it was like wow
so it wasn't quite a roller coaster but
it was like some sort of carnival ground
ride that I was going on first time
bombing on stage
this wasn't bombing this was that I was
singing you got to go back back back to
school again while stepping backwards
not realizing that there was no back on
the stage and just fell off the stage
and sort of came to laying on the ground
like what just happened
that's that's a form of bombing first
pride experience it was but there was
the first time that I had ever been
amongst so many people who were like me
but were also so diverse it's like
18,000 people and it's very clear and
very funny I just remember like it's
like sweaty it's the middle of summer
and you're in this giant like exhibition
hole like dancing and it's just like
it's very just like magical to be in a
in a space where there's like so many
different people because like normally
when you go to a queer space the people
often like look like you they're the
same age as you and so on but at Mardi
Gras and pride events in general
everybody's like different everybody
comes together and that's what I love
about pride and my Teager on those sorts
of events first pet first pet stories
never end on a happy note do they
because they're all gonna be dead by now
unless it's like a turtle like a go up
the ghost turtle that lives so like 400
years in which case it'll probably be
telling a story about how you died one
day because in the future sea creatures
have probably taken over the planet once
the humans are gone and they'll find out
all technology and learn how to talk or
something I don't know
first my bad phone this was before I had
a phone but I remember being in the bike
bike racks the bike the place where the
bikes are where kids ride their bikes to
school and and this kids sort of started
bullying me and like was shoving me my
friend Scott Martin was there and this
boy was like shoving me and I was like
don't do that he's like why what are you
gonna do about it and I was like I'm
gonna call the police and he's like what
on I'm like my mobile phone I was like
Scott get my mobile phone out of my
backpack Thanks laughing because I
didn't have a mobile phone and he and
the kid was like oh and ran off and I
was like oh thank God he didn't call my
bluff calling his bluff first time in
drag there's several of these I know
it's first time but like that the first
official time was New Year's Eve 2000
2001 my friends and I went to a circle
party in Melbourne called magnitude and
my friend Linda who was a lesbian I
think she like had a crush on me and
kind of thought that if I was in drag
and somehow it all made more sense which
oddly it did that night that was like
the first official time of Courtney act
stripper heels that's it I'm all out oh
this bowl is dusty
[Music]